they do simple lives now look at this
woman on the left here and look at this
guy with the hat here check this out
this guy's a proper hero police here
watch this here what's this
so she comes and you see what she do
i found this all funny
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this is going to be an interesting video
yeah we're going to be watching a a
video it's a documentary
um i'll put the link whereas you can
watch the whole thing um
it's going back about the 1902s and the
1905
the early 1900s and looking at these
colors and
look at these videos first time in color
yeah
and it's quite interesting actually i've
caught a haram police in one of these
yeah it's quite interesting you need to
watch it yeah it's actually funny i
caught an actual haram police who was
enjoying a good enough forbidden evil
even though i don't know
where he went about it but that's a
different story let's look at the way
these people live their lives
and let's learn some lessons from us i'm
going to play this for you guys here
and as you're watching this look at look
at the females here
look look at them look how they're
covered yeah
so women do not show
look they do not show their hair they
are covered properly
you know properly yeah they they are
covered
properly and they've got like our last
one to put their
garments over their bottoms yeah look at
them you cannot see their body
shape their figure look at how they are
covered yeah
you know um look at this these are
british
females these are british girls yeah
look at them look at them
and look at the men the men as well you
know they're dressed up
in a in a nice way as well and it's very
cool guys look at this
young girl you know look at the way she
is it's like it's a hijab it's actually
hijab this is
it's a you know proper hijab you know
and now what i want to bring you to you
guys attention i want to play the quran
please
a bit in a minute yeah okay is that the
far right and people like thomas
robinson and evie yemeni and lauren
sovereign
and um britain first
whoever you want to name it here they
come and say oh if they knew
if our ancestors our great-grandfather's
grandparents knew
that what this country has come to
talking about you know muslims in
general
they would be turning in their graves to
be honest the only thing i agree with
you on that statement is that they'll be
turning in their graves and how will
they be turning their graves
they'll be turning in their graves
knowing what you have become and i'm
talking about the far right here okay
not the general bridge for me
what you have become yeah the
things that you've accepted today that
they will never accept the way they live
their life
all you do is sniff coke yeah take
people's money
you live in a bloody mansion yeah that's
that's
true you have rolex's fifteen four five
hundred pounds jackets
um and the lifestyle that you're living
is so far from these guys that if your
great grand
your ancestors came to britain they will
feel more at home and more at ease
and more uh using culturally or
religiously
more connected to muslims than
yourselves
they would be turning in their grace
they'll be ashamed to see what the hell
you have become you know and these
people
as you can see in the uh in in the video
yourself
these people lived by morality they
believed in god
unlike you they believed in god you know
they live their lives in a proper manner
in a respectful
proper manner you know they didn't
believe in all these crazy
things that are coming out today you
know which is a norm you know they never
believed any of these
they would feel more close at home with
the muslims so
before you come and question us go and
look at your heritage
go and look at your culture go look at
your past your history
and how your ancestors live their lives
yeah and i would say you know it's
actually beautiful looking at this video
actually beautiful simple-minded people
living simple lives
yeah believing in god you know living
their life in morality i did a recent
video about ask your
dad's number experiment we went to
people and told them about why don't
like the muslim way of getting to know
somebody going and speaking to the
father i am very certain and very sure
that back in those days they would do
the same thing
if they wanted to get married they would
not go sleep around and do all this kind
of stuff and you know
they would do it in a respectful way you
know so these people
your ancestors if they came alive
if they were alive today they would be
ashamed of you guys they're absolutely
ashamed of you guys
you know i'm talking about the far right
once again i'm gonna make that very
clear yeah
um and now watching further still work
for us in barrow england 1902 yeah
okay and if i'm not mistaken they even
had trains that was segregated yeah okay
so look at this interesting video here i
caught her on please here by the way
it's quite
it's quite fun to check this out um
okay so the same thing again the same
thing again you've got
um they leave in the work yeah look at
the modesty that they have
yeah look how modest they are and i'm
not just talking about the garments
look at the modesty that they have that
uh generally
um females look they they cover their
face and they don't want to be seen on
camera
and they're running yani look this is
this is the and what this is for most
male and females are trying to get
straight yeah okay but the thing is look
look
look this is look look right from the
corner
they're just going about their business
they don't want to be seen on camera
they just see it as a respectful thing
now this is quite interesting yeah
um but it's actually quite a beautiful
scene you know because back in
those days people lived their lives in
such simple ways
they were happy they knew what happiness
was instead of
you know having this materialistic
things or whatever it may be yeah they
live simple lives now look at this woman
on the left here
and look at this guy with the hat here
check this out this guy's a proper hero
police here
watch this here what's this so she comes
and you see what she do i found this so
funny look at the girl she's like
hey look look at this guy he's up from
her please look at him
is that look what are you doing
i thought that's so funny
and then she runs off i found that so
funny
i want to watch that again that was that
was actually so funny
okay look i'm hungry guys i don't know
if he's her husband here
but he starts switching come on like at
least what's wrong with you know there's
nothing wrong with being on camera but
okay okay propaganda
oh just i found that actually really
cute i was that was actually very cute
and
definitely i would not go about advising
people
in that way um but it's just a beautiful
video and i genuinely found this
beautiful such
this video so beautiful it's so nice and
it's beautiful you know just just living
that simple life
and like i said before i hope this is uh
benefited you guys brother and sisters
you know alhamdulillah subhanallah
we do not change the quran islam does
not need reformation the quran is not
reformation you know people have changed
their ways we as muslims were sticking
to our origins
and that's the quran and the sunnah yeah
and the way
of the sahaba yeah the salah salaf yeah
may allah be pleased with all of them
and this is what we're going to be
sticking to inshallah talk that they
have judgment and inshallah we should
strive to bring sisters
do not change your ways and be one of
those one of these people
you know you have these so-called
ex-muslims who are affected by this
post-colonial masters
uh order syndrome you know it's actually
a syndrome i call it pakemaster pcmos
here
it's a syndrome yeah you know oh no
no islam changes
like especially the prophet salallahu's
marriage
it's one of the big topics that you know
i left islam because of this year
okay all right if you lived 100 years
ago in their time would you have a
problem
no the only reason you have that problem
is because of the times that you live
and your masters you have to obey your
masters because you're still in shock
oh yes yes master please you know that's
it so brother sisters
thank you for watching me i love this
you guys hope you guys benefited from
this video
and the haram police guy enjoying good
and for believer all the time inshallah
with god
good manners till next time assalamu
alaikum welcome to about
do not forget to subscribe and share and
keep an eye out for our gift salaam
dining for your chance to win a meal for
four
goodbye